هي رافعات عملاقه عاديه كما تبدو وموجوده
في كل موانئ امريكا لكن القلق يساور
المسؤولين حولها كونها صينيه الصنع ويمكن
ان تستخدمها كادوات تجسس محتمله حسب تقرير
مسؤولون في الامن القومي والبنتاجون
يقولون ان الرافعات التي تصنعها شركه
استشعار متطوره تستطيع تسجيل وتتبع مصدر
ووجهات الحاويات حتى في موانئ يستخدمها
الجيش الامريكي وبالتالي يمكن لهذه
الرافعات جمع معلومات استخباريه عن
المعدات العسكريه التي تشحن لدعم العمليات
العسكريه الامريكيه في الخارج ما يعيد الى
الاذهان موضوعه معداته شركه الاتصالات
الصينيه هواوي
الذي تواجهه الولايات المتحده وهيمنه
الصين على الكثير من التكنولوجيا
المستخدمه في التصنيع لذلك في اي وقت
تستخدم فيه الولايات المتحده اتصالات
صينيه شركه تصنيع رافعات صينيه او اي
معدات صينيه متطوره جدا تجعلها عرضه لوصول
الصين الى البيانات
عام 2021 عثر عملائه الاف بي اي على متن
سفينه شحن تنقل رافعه
على معدات لجمع معلومات استخباراتيه لكن
مسؤولين الامن القوميه لم يذكروا ما اذا
كانوا قد وجدوا اي حالات محدده لاستخدام
رافعات الشركه في التجسس وتشغل الرافعات
عبر برامج حاسوب صينيه يقول مسؤولون
امريكيون انهم يتلقون احيانا الدعم من
مواطنين صينيين ما قد يكون احد سبل جمع
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
الشركات هذه الصينيه لن تسمح لاحد انه
يقترب من اجهزتها او يبرمجها بطريقتهم
لانها هي مخصصه ومصنوعه في الصين ومبرمجه
في الصين هذا سبب انهم جايبين المبرمجين
الصينيين هذا السبب فيها بالنسبه للنقطه
الثانيه اي جهاز يوصلك للانترنت تقدر انت
ترسل المعلومات اللي تحتاجها لو مثلا في
كاميرات في الرافعات هذه لو في اي اجهزه
تحسس في الرافعات ممكن توصل المعلومات الى
الى الصين
ووفق تقارير امنيه تستطيع الصين عبر
التحكم عن بعد الرافعات خنقه حركه المرور
في الموانئ وفي السنوات الاخيره اشار
مسؤول الامن القومي الى مجموعه من المعدات
المصنعه في الصين منها انظمه فحص الامتعه
والمحولات الكهربائيه التي يمكن ان تسهل
المراقبه او الاضطرابات في الولايات
المتحده حسب
الطول العربيه من ميناء بالتيمور في ولايه
مريلاند